in terms of using nfts for real world
use cases ticketing would be the biggest
one that we've seen so far I think I
think and how do you see that evolving
and what do you see after ticketing as
the next big real world use case for
nfts I think other functional things
that apps or email confirmations do I
think reservations couponing a lot of
what you see in app culture I think nfts
can really play a role leveling up in
video games I really think that every
airline ticket is going to be an nft
instead of a QR code I think when we
have scaled nft readers then it's gonna
be really interesting like how's that
going to look could you imagine going to
a supermarket and like just scanning
your phone and because you have a
certain nft your grocery bill is 20 less
hello everyone this is Anthony and
you're listening to the disruptive
podcast today we have our first guest
and who's no other than garyvee himself
how you doing today Gary well brother
sold one and I'm proud of you man thank
you thank you starting off strong it's
all downhill from here I'm kidding I'm
kidding it's gonna get
this so you know I want to talk about V
friends V con
some other topics but before we get into
that I want to start with you and your
background on nft so when you first
heard about nfts and what was your first
interaction with them
so crypto kitties in 17 was the first
time something was on my radar I was
like that's cool because the garage sale
the Collectibles but that lasted like a
day of like maybe 40 minutes of homework
and it was just on my radar
then NBA Top Shot
I got a preview it was coming in the
fall of 2020 uh investor friend of mine
said speak to Rohan loved it thought it
was so neat I thought it was really cool
was very into sports card collecting at
the time and still I'm but like really
hot on it you know things have been flow
and
um
got busy because it was also during
covid and like I was just running the
company and
um watched it and it was like oh that's
really interesting and then it exploded
I was like oh [__] I missed the
opportunity and like you know kind of
like man and then that got me into
crypto punks
Uh Kevin Rose from moonbirds and I have
been friends for a long time and he's
like you know what do you think about
crypto punks and I was like you know I'm
not aware of that and then did like a
ton of homework on that got really in
love with that thought that was super
cool
and so you know that was kind of the
journey and then I started doing a lot
of homework on older projects which I
like quite a bit and
um and then probably around February of
21 I decided that I wanted to do
my own project I had this big concept
called workplace Warriors they were
little toys
of like things like patience and
compassion that I thought if people had
them on their desk they would have
better day to day and I kind of took the
essence of that and uh and used it as a
foundation to what I wanted to create
which was be friends and with a few
friends you know the whole mission of
you friends is kind of amplify your
voice to skill garyvee and I was not
just garyvee like you know like I'm
passionate about certain positive back
attributes but just to amplify good at
scale
were you was it the timing just right
because I feel like you're at the point
where you know you've kind of done as
much as you could do with like the
social I mean you can still make content
but would you still have gone ahead and
launched v-friends without the nft
without that technology like did the
timing the timing line up or because I
feel like you're at that Pinnacle where
I think that to your point I don't think
I don't think I the answer is probably
right to your point I'd already had the
meetings of launching a toy business
around workplace Warriors so it was to
your Point Brewing I had I feel like I
have a long way to go on the Gary V of
it all and I could but
that doesn't change the fact that my
voice doesn't resonate for a lot of
people I'm humbled to my core that my
voice resonates with so many people I'm
also incredibly aware that it it's a
voice that is unknown to weigh more and
it is a voice especially mine that
doesn't resonate to some people
um you know it's too aggressive it's too
competitive and so I'm um I'm empathetic
to that and to your point yes I feel
like the timing was great
um but the technology and kind of what
was happening in the space really spoke
to it
I I thought that too
um and you know be friends what you've
accomplished so far you know I I want to
I think it's amazing uh how do you feel
like what have you learned from May 2021
to now
I'm I feel very focused I feel really
happy about where I am I feel like it's
on its path a lot has happened v-con was
a huge success the three conferences
that came along with series one was very
important to me
um we've done some meaningful awareness
executions Toys R Us Macy's
collaboration
um you know the Uno collaboration a lot
of street wear and fashion so really
happy with like the early stages that
but most importantly I'm pumped that I'm
building the organization the talent you
know hiring a lot of former Vayner
employees or other employees has been
really fun and fruitful and feels very
much like it's working
and so you know I think caught up a
little bit in the hype of it all like
feel like I could have done a better
like in this chord I like did a lot of
great things very active but definitely
got a little bit caught up in the summer
of love and like you know like maybe
hyperbolized a little bit too much about
where like long term I feel like the
Project's going to be incredibly
unbelievable but like felt like I
learned that I you know I get in this
mindset that I'm part of the community
but I'm not I'm the founder and operator
of it so learn some of those lessons
um but you know really proud of like
putting out all the content I did about
99 going to zero that was like really
important at the height of it all so
that's good
um you know just building building yeah
uh
you know since I've been following you
your audience very important to you and
I what I like about you and this is just
your style not that it's a bad thing to
sell to your audience but you really
besides like a some wine sneakers a book
you really have chosen not to monetize
your audience and yeah not that not that
V France has but have you found that V
friends where it did take a somewhat of
a significant significant investment for
a lot of people to to buy the nft how's
your relationship has it changed with
them yeah what a small percentage Yeah
with 95 I'm referring to the ones what I
mean is like you know they bought a
v-friend because they're trying to flip
it trying to make a quick Buck yeah yeah
I mean it definitely I think that's a
great call out it was the most sec to
your point for a decade outside of the
occasional 20 thing I wasn't selling
courses I didn't buy an island I didn't
do a lot of things right
um which is fine and like I don't think
that that's bad it's just not what I had
done yeah for me be friends was less
about monetizing the audience and
creating and new universe like to me
what's really fun is like I didn't stop
making content I didn't stop engaging
with people I haven't stopped going live
I don't stop emailing and replying like
nothing has changed with the audience
other than
the key was I the way I priced it was
what's the conference worth over three
years and so I looked at South by
Southwest I wanted the conference to be
the punch line and then everything else
be kind of added value right the whole
thing got so hot that the prices went
crazy and people were buying them at
prices way above mint
and then with series two I wanted to
make sure the trading cards were very
collectible and like very like I always
with everything that I've done with be
friends I wanted to make sure the real
life thing was either right at or close
to the value of the original price so
when I look at the sports card Market
you know I thought what if I made
something that was a thousand dollar box
now I didn't feel like I closed the gap
on like the conference I feel like it
was like you know you know three four
thousand dollar conference for a weekend
type and three years and this is the
price with the cards I felt more of it
was like maybe half the value maybe it
was a 500 box or a 600 box
um so that's how I think about Stuff
Plus with the blockchain you're able to
provide surprise values and all these
other things so you know I think yes I
do the to answer your question directly
do I believe that after going all those
decades without you know quote unquote
selling things to the audience and now
having a major project that for some
people it did change it yes and and
what's funny is for some people on both
sides the people that maybe spent money
uh that they couldn't afford to lose or
like bought at the top of the market and
the things gone down they may have a
negative sentiment but even for it
changed my relationship with a lot you
know the amount of people that made an
extraordinary amount of money they're
they're more quote unquote happy with me
and so you know money [__] up a lot of
things and so like it was definitely big
enough that it was like because I'm
thinking for the rest of my life
um
I thought
it'll be good in the end and so that's
what made me go there
um
that's a practical way of looking at it
you know I it was the V friends with
first nft I bought and you know if
you're practic you could break it down
to okay what's the value of a conference
or what's the value of this access yes
correct and you know it made sense a lot
of times at least especially at first CI
things to get crazy yes but you probably
didn't want things going that crazy that
way not that you know but I but I don't
always said what did you learn I wish I
was like I've Supreme confidence in
myself plus I know who I am meaning I
know what my intent is I know what my
capacity is I know what my talents are
and so you know where I where I think I
made a micro misstep is I just think I'm
going to build the best project of all
time and I don't I feel like that's fine
but I don't think I need to say it as
much in the Discord as I did during the
height of the summer so
you know to your point I don't love when
things run up that high but I'd be lying
if I didn't say I was proud of it and it
felt good at the time and and I still
knew that like I don't think I couldn't
in the when I was making 99 are going to
zero I definitely wish I made more
content of like I bet you be friends is
not like gonna stay at this price
forever too and hopefully that like you
just want to give out good content and
so that's what I think a lot about
uh VidCon yes this year 23 23 yeah
what did you learn from the first VidCon
uh you know I I assume vcon 2023 or 2022
was huge I assume you're probably wants
to make it somehow even better yes than
last year but what did you learn from
last year that you're going to implement
this year so the big joke with me and my
inner circle is that
I learned a ton the problem was 22 went
off so well yeah like we didn't deserve
it to go that well
that's your big like headline for this
podcast we were too green I never threw
up anything of that but the love and the
good like it just went too well we have
great content the community was awesome
I was bleeding out of my eyeballs to be
there for everyone and so like I feel
like so what I learned plan earlier like
we're way ahead of schedule compared to
last time
um but what's fun about 23 for me is
I do think a lot of people are going to
get a lot more value because last year
was the height of people wanting to get
educated about web 3 and and nfts and
things that nature this year it's going
to be a lot more about business a lot
more about marketing a lot more about
popular culture a lot more about
Innovation and so I'm really excited
because I think we're gonna have a much
wider broader more intriguing
uh content execution and I think that's
going to service us very well
not maybe more business instead of the
web three yeah there'll be plenty of web
3 personalities but there's gonna be a
ton of CEOs and CMOS of big companies
and and and startups and mid-sized
companies so I think you're going to get
a and I think there's a lot more
pop culture so a lot more people with
audiences for acting or for you know
entertainment that I think will create a
lot of fun panels to check out
um and to be able to provide these you
know these events or these this access
these things for uh holders
probably does that have to do with the
funding that you raised uh yeah I mean
is that is that what the funding is
going to be used for mainly or I mean
yes right but to get them to fall in
love with this you know I've heard you
say you know whether it's TV show movies
amusement parks books comic books you
know you're there's a lot of different
Avenues to push this IP yes
um which one are you most excited
animation has the chance to really hit
like
Shrek meant nothing until it premiered
you can go from zero to Icon if you get
that right so there's a lot of
excitement I have for that
collectibles
little little executions like
what if we make a candy that goes viral
like you know things like that yeah
um I want to chat a little bit about
Vayner three yes um I don't believe that
everyone knows what vayner3 is can you
just give us a quick yeah a couple
sentences on that we started a agency in
the vaynerx world separate from V
friends
um called Vayner first I was Vayner nft
we rebranded to Vayner three it's really
our Innovation agency a Consulting an
execution agency that thinks through all
the opportunities that companies have in
blockchain
in nft land but also broader than that
the reason we reframed the Vayner three
is we want to incorporate you know AI VR
AR
there's a lot of innovation going on in
the world right now at the same time and
so Avery she's incredible sits at the
helm of that and
um and hoping to get her on too one day
you will you will just leverage me I'll
help you and she's you know she's
brilliant and doing a great job running
that company and we're excited about it
um
you know big Brands you see some are
very pro-web three taking a big jump
some are hesitant um I feel like they're
waiting to see how things play out
um the ones who are optimistic why do
you see them jumping in and and likewise
the ones that are hesitant like what's
the main reason for them not to jump you
know I think government Clarity on the
hesitation
and then the ones jumping in is
they've been around the block and I've
seen Innovation first mover Advantage
matter
and so I think those are the two
clarities
um
in terms of
you know just macro big big brands with
web3 like what's the like that's the
number one Trend you're you're seeing
caution you know we're
crypto Winter though it's been a little
bit better last couple I guess some of
the recent events uh are probably not
helping like with FTX and stuff like
that yeah I mean that's really
unfortunate I don't even look at
they were more web 2 than they were in
web3 right you know to me web3 is like
you're the custodial you're in charge
right I mean I feel like that almost was
like this bad version of web 2.5 people
thought they were in web3 it was fully
Web Two not fully understanding yeah and
I think people like you know people with
bad intentions exploited that or maybe
you know I've not really because I never
had any of my you know Holdings in
exchanges I didn't really pay attention
other than the headlines but
it's hard to see how there's any good in
like a lot of these things I mean when
you're playing with people's money you
know on the back end that's how Banks
got into trouble
we've seen that through the Great
Depression and banking crisis season you
know I think
you know it's unfortunate to your point
the headlines
scare people off and you know I think
you just have to wait
uh which brand that has entered the web
space what's the best your favorite
example of whether it's a Vayner three
client or someone else like what's the
best example you can think of
I thought I liked how Nike and Adidas
took it really
that really stands out to me the
artifact acquisition the executions that
that stands out as like okay they're
like pot committed to the space
so it's like those two stand out
um
I don't want to use Vayner 3 but you
know Pepsi and Budweiser I think did a
great job of also taking it serious uh
I never got to look under the hood but I
was impressed at Lacoste had a good
execution during a down market so I I
wanted I never got to really look what
they did but that caught my attention uh
DraftKings I think you know with some of
their stuff I thought kalish was so of
it so I think that helped them
um those stand out
and in terms of uh you know the Loosely
coin term of metaverse you know I feel
like there's a long-term vision of what
people have for it and what the current
version is of it uh what what are big
Brands what are they saying about the
metaverse are they you know we have seen
some enter
um it's not it's been a space that I've
been less passionate about you're
talking about VR yeah the whole I guess
the end goal will be a fully VR
immersive experience I think people got
ahead of their skis like like I'm I
follow consumer Behavior like if people
weren't buying crypto punks in late 2020
I wouldn't have been as interested
you know until I see people really
living in VR it's hard to get excited
about the metaverse that's defined that
way you know building a Gucci store in
decentral land when there's like 12
people going there is not gonna fire me
up and then the 12 people who actually
did it on desktop you know because
nobody's really got a VR device outside
of oculus so like you know like I think
we're just far away from that and we've
always recommended in that vein to our
clients so just web3 in general the
would it be fair to say you know
ticketing in in terms of using uh nfts
for real world use cases ticketing would
be the biggest one that we've seen so
far
and how do you see uh you know special I
mean V con and then what you guys did
down in um Art Basel that sort of thing
but what would you how do you see that
evolving and what do you see after
ticketing as the next big real world use
case for nfts
I think other functional things that
apps or email confirmations do
reservations
I really think that every airline ticket
is going to be an nft instead of a QR
code I think when we have scaled nft
readers
then it's gonna be really interesting
how's that going to look yeah like just
like whether it's a phone or something
else like Boop
right yeah like could you imagine going
to a supermarket and like just scanning
your phone and because you have a
certain nft your grocery bill is 20 less
like like I think they're functional
their smart contracts are completely
easy to integrate with like the
technology is profound this is why the
concept of like the Collectibles of it
all clouded a lot of the opportunity and
I look I love Collectibles but I think
reservations couponing
um
like a lot of what you see in app
culture I think nfts can really play a
role
um leveling up in video games like
making your experiences better through
the ownership of
and so that to me is how
you mentioned so video games is an
interesting one the the whole the gaming
space
um you know what I've seen this play to
earn it's kind of
yeah the problem with play to earn is
the like plate earns great when 40
million people are playing and eight
percent care about the investing play to
earns a real problem when 100 of the
people that are playing or playing for
the investment then they're just playing
for the money not for the love and then
when there's a thing that comes along
that gives better play to earn things
they go from playing axi to playing
schmaxy it's yeah just because it's it's
I found I found that's just really
speculative you know that's
you're not playing because you love it
yeah there's not really any value being
created I didn't play Mike Tyson's punch
out because I was getting three cents
for every hour I was playing right right
so perhaps then we'll see maybe some of
the more established gaming Brands
adopting and maybe it won't be play to
earn so much maybe it's just it's gonna
be more of the ownership of the the
assets I'm not sure play to unlock right
like when you buy a crapload of stuff on
Roblox and Minecraft with real money to
have in there
but then you grow up and you want to
play fortnite it would be cool if you
could sell off all your swag
on those platforms and take your
Minecraft and Roblox money to buy
fortnite stuff instead of putting your
credit card in and buying that stuff
you're not creating an asset when you're
playing in those games it lives only
within that game but when it all goes
decentralized they become assets so now
all of a sudden all those points you
amassed on NBA 2K
can be you can when you're like I don't
play 2K anymore you can sell that on the
blockchain instead of just letting it
sit in the side of a video game yeah
well that's where you know I don't play
as many as I I'd like to anymore but you
know back in the day Halo 3 Call of Duty
I put a lot of hours into those games
right it would be nice if those things
were assets to your next yeah
for sure
um and then just one more and then it's
and it's not just gaming like how cool
is it if you had eight thousand dollars
worth of rare collectibles in that game
and you sell that off because you wanted
to do some sort of teach like somebody's
putting out a teaching nft and you get
80 hours of learning it's like why like
garage sales you've got stuff laying
around your house that might be worth
something it's in your closet
same with this your your PS5 is your
closet yeah I still have the files right
but that's right
um just just take it back to ticketing
real quick you know besides just using
nft replacing like a a digital ticket
with an nft
um
what other ways like do you see like
adding value to a customer like to maybe
incentivize them to adopt like an nft uh
as a ticket like uh Chanel
could create a Chanel house
where if you own the nft that gives you
the ability to go to the seventh floor
of their London store and have you know
cocktails and tea but if you don't you
don't right so more of the exclusive
access exclusive access right there's
also just like
where does a deed sit when you buy a
home
like you know the the head of
all the dot you know the the the state's
municipality building can burn down what
happens to all those papers no like yeah
now we're in a place where we scan them
and they're in the cloud but like
somebody like when it's decentralized
like nobody has full control of that
like people you know have to give that a
lot of thought
so like mundane things that nobody's
going to think about contracts you know
we've seen
ticketing a little bit of music but my
question is like these industries being
disrupted or being web3 signed to adopt
them what what do you see as the next
Big Industry that's gonna
be not maybe fully disruptive but web3
is going to start to enter like you know
with music right now I'd say it's very
very early
um but do you think that'll be the next
one to continue growing or will it be
gaming or
I think really any consumable is in play
like fashion gaming sports entertainment
I think all of those are going to be you
know impacted
um
you know I think I think a lot of B2B
stuff the boring legal yeah law firms
you know like just like documentation
like where did things sit
um
like I do think the entertainment
business like
why couldn't a streaming service come
along that's built on nft infrastructure
instead of like you know what I mean
like
like why couldn't that be the
subscription subscriptions contracts you
know I think a lot about so
that's what I see right now uh you know
you mentioned like in terms of fashion
so if we look at Fashion
where they're selling a physical product
you know I've been of the belief it's
very early but I've been the belief that
you know the physical products are a lot
if not all of them are going to have
like an Associated nft
they will and then the question becomes
is that physical product held up in an
exchange in a warehouse and you don't
take ownership of it like stockx
and you're just trading the nft that
represents it and then when I actually
want to get that eight million dollar
painting into my apartment I have to
burn the nft to get the actual physical
or is it just a nice
receipt
where you can separate the because once
you give it to the person if you give
them the physical and the nft well
they're detached because I can just sell
off the entity or I can just sell off
the physical and there's no technology I
can keep track yeah whereas if I sell
you a fifteen thousand dollar handbag
and I give you the nft and the handbag
sits in a mercile exchange-like
environment then I can actually trade
the nft and then if you actually want
the bag you can burn the nft in
Redemption up yeah because what I'm
getting at is you know the
especially with luxury goods but the
second hand uh secondary Market with
Fakes and that sort of thing right I've
really seen nfts as a way to help combat
that but it's so difficult now because
yeah once the technology wants a
physical product so it's correct and
once you take ownership of it you can't
you know it's not going to prove
Providence unless it's sitting but
that's important there's a lot of people
that buy something very valuable to have
they want to know it's real if they buy
it in nft form to burn to take physical
at accountability of it then you're good
that's huge yeah
that's huge yeah at least for that first
secondary sale for that first secondary
sell you got it or the ninth if nobody
ever Burns it
there could be 99 seconds I mean you
know much Arts just sitting in docks
around the world for tax Havens or how
much how much wine sitting in wine
cellars do you know how many sports
cards are sitting in safety deposit
boxes
you know like a lot of people don't need
the the actual physical thing
it I I don't I'm not my public stock is
not sitting in my hands right right the
knowledge of
um and then over time the nft becomes
the thing
owning the nft is owning the birken bag
at scale Burger bag I can only you know
rare pair of sneakers only so many
people can see me wearing them but once
this scales to like social media like
levels like people are gonna be like
what nfts does that person have
that makes sense that makes sense
um
you know we're starting to also see the
first
implements or implementation of sort of
like web3 social media I don't know how
familiar you are with it
um but the the idea of like you know
being able to
own basically the data uh that you know
whether it's the post what you're a
tweet that you put or the the creative
or
not let's not put the best way but
owning your followers being able to take
them with you transfer you know if it's
on the same protocol transform from app
to app what are your what are your
thoughts on like the whole web3 social
media scene that's inevitable
that's what that's where we're heading
for sure I just don't see why one
wouldn't work
it just
I guess the doubt is right now is just
like you know
the the chicken or they you kind of need
the people on the platform for people to
you know this is where lack of patience
comes in you know to me I'm like cool
I'll wait seven years
to let it mature I I you know the web 2
platforms they all went through that too
right that's right right like I was
having dinner or like I would have I
would me and Mark Zuckerberg would be in
the Ace Hotel
seven years into Facebook and people
like
didn't know who he was
seven years like plenty did know who he
was yeah but like plenty didn't it
and you know the current platforms uh
what year can you Google real quick what
year Uber was created
yeah exactly and then can you do me a
favor and tell me what what's the date
on that email or you got them both dust
thanks what's the date March 20 uh 2009
okay and that email
April 8th 2011. right so in two years
and one month
so that uh for everybody who's listening
I asked for the date so obviously we got
that from Dustin and then what I asked
us to look on is I have a framed email
from Uber uh thanking my brother AJ for
taking the first Uber in New York
it took Uber two years after being
invented to even test Uber in New York
City two years it took them two years
just to test New York
it takes time
wow right Isn't that cool yeah no two
full years I I mean why are you not
why is we friends not Disney I'm like I
don't know it's gonna give me 50 years
to get close so with the current web to
with the current platforms current
social media platforms do you
where do they fit in terms of like you
know it's better to put yourself out of
business before someone else does so at
some point if they feel like it's
getting close I assume they're going to
want to execute their own version yeah
so and and maybe something like I don't
think all will adopt it you know maybe
they'll and by the time they realize
maybe it'll be too late yeah of course I
mean you know Facebook as a leader has
been incredible at M A they bought
Instagram they bought WhatsApp they
tried to buy snap Tick Tock in essence
wasn't really for sale right but like I
think that
it's very clear that
you know
if if they could move
super fast they would either kill those
things or buy them for nothing but all
those deals were billions of dollars
right once something's out the bag it's
out the bag
right and so you know I think for the
meta for the tick tocks for
the linkedins the YouTubes they're gonna
have to give it a lot of thought I just
it's it's going to be tricky because you
know these the business models are all
predicated off yeah but you could have
like you know to me it's just portfolio
management yes I understand over here
Facebook or Tick Tock you make money off
of people
being in your ecosystem but why can't
you create another app that is
decentralized
that's like owning a vegan restaurant
and saying that you can't open a meat
only restaurant of course you can
so they just good I see what you're
saying yeah like why couldn't meta come
out with a decentralized social network
at scale when on both sides it's not
like you know how long it's going to be
before everyone migrates off of
centralized social networks to
decentralized social networks take time
12th 12 years 15 19.
that's the number I think of 10 plus at
least people don't even know what the
[__] we're talking about right now I
know like decentralized centralized what
are you talking about you know yeah yeah
um people are always like you know like
people also just like read a headline
and run with it like China like I've
literally had conversations with people
like they hate U.S social networks but
now like they don't care anymore because
China has Tick Tock and I'm like well
let's talk it out what does that mean
well China will have my data I'm like
everyone has your data there's not a
person on Earth that's data has not been
compromised at scale the IRS was hacked
Target was hacked MasterCard was hacked
Visa has been hacked Walmart's been
hacked like Costco's been hacked like
every government's been hacked like I
don't understand this whole like you
know yeah yeah no that makes sense
nobody's date is private nobody's what
do you think they
he's private everyone
all of them are wrong
what data you know every person give me
millions of people on the dark web have
access to when you were born
the only people have your social
security number right now
tons
but people don't realize is that there's
people don't act on like there has to be
a purpose
like I laughed that people are like I
don't want Tick Tock to to be on my
phone I'm like your phone is the problem
yeah like you your phone is the problem
your phone is is much more track like
like what are you scared of like people
stealing your money from your bank well
like your bank gives it back to you in
web 3 you can actually get [__] stolen
right people want decentralization like
one of the biggest decentralized people
got hacked and then wanted the FBI
involved well like yeah you know like
that's the hypocrisy of it like bmic too
you know what I mean like you know I
don't want Tick Tock I'm like your
phone's TR like you got your [__] GPS
on like people are funny
like
people are [__] like
worried about how much sugar is in a
Coca-Cola but then driving without a
seat belt
people like petrified like petrified of
flying while never wearing a seatbelt in
the back seat the data is clear like
people just hyperbolize [__] like
I don't know like people just talk out
of both sides of their mouth at scale
and it's boring
that's the theme I see too is like you
know it's it's everyone's kind of
pushing for self ownership self-custody
but unfortunately like you know they're
just lacking the education or or when
something does happen everyone loves the
Wild Wild West yeah until somebody
points a gun at them yeah
like
this is what I mean like where is the
thoughtfulness
uh before we wrap up I just want to talk
about uh one other industry
maybe two if we have time the music
music one so it's the Holy Grail yeah
web3 music yeah the one you've talked
about the most I think Holy Grail is
the same and again we're gonna need
Clarity of Law and all this but like
when that happens
that'll be the most fun everyone can
become an A R
it's like fun you're like oh this band's
all you know like now you know how like
the cliche thing like somebody discovers
a band or an artist they love them when
they're small they see them in a
40-person venue but when they get famous
they're like [__] sellouts it's all
it's always been the weirdest
relationship
now people will be like go go go because
I own three percent of your first album
like I want you to say I want you to be
[__] the biggest band in the world
because change you know if that happens
that'll be so cool
no I I think it's for the for the better
as well yeah otherwise you're just over
uh actually on what do you think they're
gonna do like do you think
involved they'll become marketing
agencies for if distribution and fund
and funding is taken away from them
distribution now is social media like
how many more times do we need somebody
to explode on Soundcloud and Tick Tock
for people to realize you don't need MTV
or or to get your album like like people
still deep down think like I'm gonna get
my record in the record store like I
don't understand what we're doing here
like so I think that um that would be
really cool and I think they'll evolve
they'll have to act they'll have to
provide demand value not distribution
and finance value is could we like make
the same like the is it similar to like
maybe the social media platforms like
they're gonna have to evolve and what I
mean by social media platforms
honestly this is a fun time to go there
once and for all
World let me explain to you for everyone
who's like these [__] platforms make
all the money and they're [__] using
me and I'm getting used let's just talk
about it
Dustin
do you know if it does cost or does not
cost money
to
put an ad in a newspaper do you think
you can call a newspaper and say hey I'd
like you to put a full page ad and
here's what I'd like you to put and I'd
prefer you charge me nothing
that is not possible Right do you think
I can call CNN right now and say hey CNN
hey Fox hey CBS hey ABC I would like to
run a video in between your hit shows
a commercial and I would like to pay you
nothing for that
okay that billboard outside right behind
you do you think I can call that number
and say hey I'd like to put up the vinyl
that goes there to say follow V friends
on social media and please charge me
nothing
do you believe I can call Howard Stern's
Show on Sirius and say Hey Howard listen
you know how you do read these things in
between the show and you're like go to
befriends.com to do you think Howard
would do that for free cool now
these social networks say hey we're open
create an account
post something and something can happen
and it costs zero
from us this whole concept that these
social networks have [__] the man the
man has used social networks for their
benefit
I've built a humongous audience on
YouTube Facebook Twitter Instagram Tick
Tock Snapchat and I haven't paid those
companies a single penny
and when I sell empathy and empathy and
all this like that where does that come
from
this is a ludicrous conversation
I can't wait for decentralized social
networks where you have to build your
own audience
where you're not maybe I guess not
relying on an algorithm to you post and
people are there you're getting access
to people
people love to cry about things that
they take for granted
when I was older I was like wait a
minute what
I could just send email not be charged
Twitter wait so let me get this right
this is why I freaked out about Twitter
back to buying stuff like so
I get to post
people follow me and they can share what
I so I get word of mouth and
distribution and the platform's not
charging me
and by the way here it comes
Twitter's about to charge for no like
and everyone's and you know what
everyone's gonna do [__] this [__]
why do we chart because you don't you
don't want ads you don't want them to
monetize like this
uh my data is being monetized is [__]
lap by the way on the record
I'd be really sad if that went away I
like that most of the ads that I see
have something of interest for me
I don't like the ads on television I
don't need diapers or tampons when I'm
watching this [__] like I don't need it
I don't need your beer I'm not gonna
drink your beer I don't need that ad I
like New York Jets ads
it's a better experience when I'm
targeted the whole thing [__] pisses
me off
it really does not because I love social
now I don't give a [__] about it I could
give a [__] about social networks I just
don't like when people talk without a
complete conversation
it's free
Instagram is free
for you
so they monetize by advertisers coming
to you that's like television
you know who else monetizes your data
television
you know who else monetize your data
newspapers you're reading the Wall
Street Journal you turn the page you
don't want to see that full page ad of
some financial service but they know
that if you're reading the Wall Street
Journal you might want Financial
Services
I don't know like people are
very interesting to me
because they're making money they're
making money
or they're getting entertainment
yeah no Tick Tock does not charge you
for all that entertainment every kid on
earth
gets unlimited entertainment on tick
tock for free meanwhile they have to pay
20 bucks a month or whatever [__]
Netflix how much is Netflix now
15. right yeah right like I don't get it
Like It's Entertainment for free it's
building audience for free like how do
you think this works I can't wait for
decentralization when it's based on
Merit and not the algo and the audience
is there we'll see how much people
reminisce about this time and what they
complained about well it might come soon
later we'll see what happens with with
Twitter what you know like you said
that's a fascinating thing brother
people are funny man
Waters free by the way
putting it out there for Millions you
know I'm part of Charity water so I know
it's not free for a lot of people and
not easy but like just to remind
everybody water for a lot of people if
you're listening to this podcast it is
very likely that you have water
in your but you pay you'll pay four
bucks for a bottled water
and you have it for free people are just
funny like the things that people talk
about and do like you know how hot I am
on this this [__] yeah yeah brother's
the [__] on me crying
put out our Starbucks
for coffee which used to be a quarter
five minutes ago
uh just have a couple minutes left just
want to do some quick quick questions
uh just got four of them here which V
friend are you most excited to develop
yeah I'm not asking necessarily what's
your favorite which one you're because
it's the only the thoughtful
three-horned harpic is the only made up
character in all of me friends every
single be friend otherwise is something
people know
and so it's most fun to develop because
I have to develop it like what are harp
you know I think about the three-horned
harpic like Chewbacca
Chewbacca was in Star Wars and they
needed to develop it but later because
it was so successful you like could
develop all Wookies not just Chewbacca
so the harpic is not Chewbacca it's a
harpic it's a wookie so like I have to
develop the whole genre of them
this is just the thoughtful one like it
could be like if you ask me like 16
years from now give me a hot take guess
I'd be like oh the harpix like spun out
of the friends and there's just like a
whole harpic thing
uh how did you come up with the hard
pick
I think at some point in the drawing I I
gotta go look back at the video I feel
like I was so I was drawing I was
drawing with intent like I gotta draw a
cougar oh [__] how am I a drunk cougar
like and then at some point I think it
just got tired and bored and like
mundane and I was like just drew it
it was almost like a combination of a
lot of other
things I was wrong and I was kind of
just like
I'm gonna make this it was just kind of
like very creative good good
um what other nft projects besides
yourself of course uh yours are you most
interested in watching develop Moon
Birds because I'm a huge Kevin Rose fan
board eight because it became the
dominant leader and be fun to watch them
world of women I think is still a really
significant one
Doodles is interesting to me
um personally pudgy penguins
is interesting to me personally just
like operators that I think are really
trying to do it
um
you know
though I mean there's a ton that I'm
keeping an eye on Swampers you know like
just little one wolf game has been very
successful I went that was like the one
of the biggest things I like jumped on
AJ loved it I got caught up in the hype
of it all like just got excited you know
um and it's done very well actually I'm
a little bit out of the loop for this
question because I really don't even
have a great update on any of the things
I just mentioned we're focused on I've
been so focused on be friends but I'm
excited to see what happens with those
and really honestly everybody who's
given it a real run anybody who has good
intent and as a real story dead fellas
but you know like anybody who I think is
like trying to really do it it'll be fun
to see how it goes yeah I'm excited uh
and of the celebrities that embraced web
3 and I have teas uh so far which one
are you most excited to see what their
next move is that's a great question
you know I love Snoop because he's so
entrepreneurial like he's a real
entrepreneur besides being a rap icon or
a hip-hop icon um
Seth Green
I think it's like really about that life
yeah I'm really interested in him too
yeah I think he's just a great
Storyteller like he can like make him
like he could make E.T and if that E.T
was original like whatever he's gonna do
he's a different level Storyteller he's
got that George Lucas Steven Spielberg
like DNA yeah I mean I don't think he's
had that caliber yet but like he's got
home run hitting ability like if you
told me again you're a genie from the
future and like Gary guess what happened
green put out a project and then six
years later a movie came out and it was
the Shrek it was the Frozen it was the
E.T of its time and that like massively
impact the you know I think he gets it
and last last real quick one sentence to
uh to leave with uh the listeners today
that I'm extremely proud of you
for coming out of your comfort zone to
do this and that if you can do this
everyone can do this and everyone should
do the things that they have in their
stomach that they're scared or reserved
to do I thought you did a great job I do
this a lot like some people are animated
like I am others like go right down the
highway and I think that's what you did
here and I think you'll continue to get
better and I can't wait to see your
100th episode thanks so much appreciate
it cheers
foreign
[Music]